the Starbucks off of rainbow and Oaky
made history last month as the first
Nevada location to unionize and it's
catching on another location announcing
today its intent to follow in their
footsteps Ryan Matthey joins us now live
from the location at today in Azure in
the Northwest Valley with some of the
hurdles they face though Ryan
it's Brian that location voted to
unionize about a month ago they're still
without the contract for that
representation they say they add it's a
whole process it began with that vote
and the story right behind me here they
say they began that process this week
it's scary like we're going against a
huge company that makes a lot of money
and currently has a lot of power over us
these are just some of the 16 Baristas
or Partners as they're called that
signed onto this letter to the coffee
giant CEO it reads this company has
failed to provide many of its employees
with a stable work environment but is
still expecting us to progress it's
extremely high paced high pressure very
stressful you know up to 700 orders a
day they say with not enough staff to
keep up hours were cut after the holiday
season but customer demand stays High
most Partners seen over 20 hours a week
they say cut down now to almost half you
hear you know you might lose your job or
you don't want to even want your manager
to be mad at you like you still have to
work with your manager you don't want
things to be awkward you don't want to
feel like you're targeting them but
ultimately like this is our problem with
corporate we don't have any of those
benefits yet they're following in the
footsteps of Lily Savita store which
joined nearly 300 other unionized
locations last month with the vote ass
they now have to collectively agree on
what they want higher pay better health
insurance guaranteed hours all on the
table she says which is then bargained
with Starbucks corporate a model for
others wanting to do the same for a
battle that doesn't end with the vote
we're the first of many and I think
every Starbucks is going to unionize so
I think it's just an obstacle right now
we care about our customers we care
about the work that we do and you know
it's hard to care for our customers when
we're not being cared for
now those Partners they're organizing a
sip in on Saturday that's where they sit
inside the store from 11 o'clock to
three o'clock they're inviting Community
Partners and hoping the public will join
them to show their support reporting
live from Tanaya and Azure primathy a
news now Ryan thanks and when Ryan
reached out to Starbucks on this this is
what they sent back quote we respect our
partners right to organize but believe
that working directly side by side
without a third party is the best way to
continue to elevate the partner
experience at Starbucks